[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes locales et régionales
voici tout de suite les titres de
l'actualité de ce journal dehors et sans
masque
vous en avez peut-être rêver ce sera
sûrement bientôt une réalité des villes
sont déjà revenus sur l'obligation du
port du masque
reportage à suivre à arcachon avec la
chaîne télé 7 la chaîne du groupe sud
ouest lui n'a pas besoin de masques dans
l'espace
thomas pesquet en mission dans la
station spatiale internationale a pris
le port de répondre à des élèves cette
semaine un échange suivi par nos
confrères de la dépêche du midi elle
redonne de l'espoir et un avenir à de
nombreux jeunes l'école de la deuxième
chance c'est comme cela qu'elle
s'appelle forme aux métiers de la mer en
martinique
une plongée grâce à la rédaction devient
atv sur place nous vous raconterons
également laventure d'un vosgien qui
vient de boucler un tour de france à
vélo de 4000 km un vrai tour de force
que nous racontera à la chaîne vient
vosges et puis cette exclusivité du à
nos partenaires de la provence des
images de l'exposition un ipod qui
débutera dans une semaine au stade
vélodrome
une exposition pour les fans des rolling
stones ce en fin de journal est ce la
fin d'une époque au moins en extérieur
le port du masque pourrait ne plus être
obligatoire dans la rue dès cet été une
bonne nouvelle avec l'arrivée des
chaleurs estivales d'arcachon dans le
sud-ouest le maire de la ville
il foule on a déjà levé l'interdiction
depuis le 19 mai dernier
pour l'heure les habitants restent
néanmoins prudents un reportage sur
place de célia vallée pour tv7 la chaîne
du groupe sud ouest prendre le soleil
respirer l'air marin et le tout sans
masque d'arcachon il n'est plus
obligatoire à l'extérieur depuis le 19
mai 100 livres aux cetc particulier
koala avec le soleil les lunettes le
masque est tombé
non mais franchement agréable j'avoue
que je suis bien sur mac
le message est bien passé pour les
locaux mais les touristes eux ne sont
pas forcément au courant de cette mesure
pour une majorité d'entre eux le mot
d'ordre c'est de rester prudent et a pas
de
l'information n'a pas circulé donc voilà
on continue à porter le masque en bon
citoyen on n'a pas encore été vaccinés
donc on préfère le garder et puis on a
des proches à risque donc on préfère
elle prétend plus de trente neuf mille
personnes ont déjà reçu une première
dose de vaccin d'arcachon attention le
masque n'est plus obligatoire mais
l'épidémie elle est toujours bien
présente en extérieur c'est le bon sens
qui prévaut citons dans une rue bondée
je pense qu'il vaut mieux par précaution
encore porter le masque c'est trop tôt
pour l'enlever
il ya seulement un tiers des français
vaccinés par respect pour les deux tiers
qui ne le sont pas soyons encore un peu
prudent par contre au travail à
l'intérieur dans les voyages transports
ont continué à porter le masque avec un
taux d'incidence de 84 cas pour 100000
habitants en gironde un taux toujours
supérieur au seuil d alerte
la vigilance reste de mise notamment
dansé ville très touristique est très
fréquenté en période estivale
assouplissement des restrictions aussi
pour les personnes âgées dans les ehpad
les seniors peuvent de nouveau recevoir
leurs proches le temps d'une visite
un changement qui fait du bien au moral
des résidents même si vous allez voir
les règles varient selon les
établissements
un reportage de tva en bretagne de chloé
et brel et de lisa hervé sert devenu une
routine pour viviane plusieurs fois par
semaine elle rend visite à sa tante
berthe et si dans sa chambre qu'elle
peuvent se toucher être ensemble en
toute intimité
un soulagement après des mois de
restrictions
c'était gênant quand on était dans une
salle plexiglas entre nous et voir la
personne derrière avec ses classes c'est
un petit peu çà çà çà couple quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas le coup le contact
pareil et déjà moi j'ai on vient d'avoir
une petite fille je vais montrer sur mon
téléphone on voit pas l voyez pas pareil
ici dans cet ehpad aval d'anast les
visites en chambres sont autorisés
depuis fin février
et aujourd'hui plus besoin de prendre
rendez vous il ya eu beaucoup d'émotion
au retour des familles en fait beaucoup
d'émotion pour les résidents mais
beaucoup d'émotion aussi pour le
personnel de revoir une vie normale
enfin entre guillemets un
assouplissement permis grâce à la
vaccination c'est une volonté de
l'établissement et puis on peut se
permettre de le faire parce qu'on a
pratiquement 99% des réseaux non
vaccinés et 84 % du personnel
donc on sait que le risque qu'il est
très limité aux tripes à d' autres
protocoles ici à hédé bazouges les
visites en chambre et les retours en
famille restent encore rares
nous avons maintenu les visites sur
rendez vous afin de régler le nombre de
personnes présentes dans l'établissement
mais également pour avoir une équité sur
le nombre de visites que chaque résident
et est en droit d'avoir ses mesures
strictes pourraient toutefois s'alléger
ce week-end avec la fête des mères il
est parti il y à un peu plus d'un mois
désormais dans l'espace mais n'en reste
pas moins en liaison avec la terre
l'astronaute thomas pesquet actuellement
en mission dans la station spatiale
internationale a participé cette semaine
un échange avec une cinquantaine
d'élèves de la région où toulouse
collégiens et lycéens ont ainsi pu lui
poser des questions sur son métier et
ses activités dans l'espace clément gaci
du journal de la dépêche du midi a pu
assister à cet échange organisé par le
centre national d'études spatiales
il a recueilli les impressions des
élèves écoutent l on se dit qu'il est
quand même à 400 kilomètres au dessus de
nos têtes et que c'est fluide on arrive
à le voir facilement et répond à nos
questions
je trouve ça assez impressionnant et ça
donne envie j'aimerais bien bossé dans
le spatial plus tard et c'est vraiment
un rêve inaccessible ce serait
d'atteindre l'espace comme lui
j'ai hâte de voir mes pensées partir ben
alias assez parler l'anglais comme il
peut parler le prince et je trouve ça
que la finale est magique et j'ai moi
j'ai bien aimé qui flottaient place
carnot on voit la présente heures
comment commencer dans l'espace et ses
ressentis sans transition dans ce
journal le cancer du sein et vous le
savez le plus fréquent chez la femme
pour soulager les patientes des douleurs
post opératoires
certains hôpitaux à l'image de
l'établissement rené du boss à pontoise
leur propose de repartir avec un coussin
en forme de coeur ce dispositif a été
imaginé par un médecin américain et
s'appuie sur des couturières bénévoles
une belle initiative que nous raconte
angélique boilet devient 95,6 vous
montre quelques modèles pour julie ce
sera celui aux couleurs acidulées ce
coussin en forme de coeur doit permettre
de la soulager
je vous propose de venir placer votre
bras la veille
cette patiente de 51 ans a subi une
mastectomie du sein droit
dans quelques heures julie va pouvoir
rentrer chez elle et pourra l'utiliser
autant de fois que nécessaire ça une
visée dans un premier temps antalgiques
parce qu'on touche très souvent à la
chaîne ganglionnaire et on a ce qu'on
appelle le retour lymphatique et donc ça
c'est vrai que cette sensation
d'engourdissement du bras donc le
coussin vraiment sert d'appui et puis
aussi cette notion d' intégrer au
cerveau le fait que le sang ne soit plus
là des effets immédiatement ressenti par
la patiente savard rapportent avoir
apporté du confort j'ai santé en mettant
le coussin sous les aisselles va la
chaleur franchement ça m'a fait beaucoup
de bien
l'hôpital de pontoise dans le val d'oise
propose à chaque patiente ayant subi une
chirurgie suite un cancer du sein de
repartir avec un coussin ces petits
coeurs molletonné sont confectionnés par
des mains bénévoles mis au point par un
médecin américain
ils répondent à un cahier des charges
bien précis à commencer par sa taille le
tissu utilisé du coton impérativement
sans oublier le rembourrage pile-poil
166 déjà investi pendant le premier
confinement nathalie a ensuite découvert
l'existence de ces coussins à l'été 2020
et a tout de suite été séduite par la
cause si un simple petit coussin comme
ça en tissu ça peut apporter du bien ben
quelque part moi ça me
j'ai l'impression d'être utile et je
trouve ça sympathique de se dire qu'il
ya une femme qui peut être grâce au fait
que j'ai passé une petite heure à faire
un coup simple ça va lui éviter de
prendre trop d'antalgiques je pense que
ça apporte aussi un soutien
le cancer du sein reste le plus fréquent
chez la femme à la maison chez vous dans
votre voiture ou encore au travail
le numérique est présent partout dans
nos vies et notamment dans les villes la
smart city soit la ville intelligente en
français est l'un des enjeux du futur
pour les collectivités et à monaco de
nombreuses applications et intelligence
artificielle sont déjà présentes dans le
quotidien des habitants star portage sur
place de christophe rigaud pour le grand
jt des territoires la ville de demain
est en train de s'inventer ici à monaco
grâce au numérique la principauté est
devenue un véritable laboratoire de la
smart city la ville intelligente du
futur en 2019
monaco a été le premier pays à lancer la
5g et possède aujourd'hui l'une des deux
fibres les plus rapides au monde grâce à
ses infrastructures et à des capteurs
qui remonte des données en temps réel la
principauté teste de nouvelles
innovations notamment pour la mobilité
aujourd'hui les bus à monaco lorsqu'il
arrive devant un feu ont automatiquement
le feu vert pour favoriser la mobilité
et les transports en commun et
l'environnement s'est fait par les
capteurs s'est fait part de l'analyse
qui permet justement de d'avoir une
ville intelligente et rendre une ville
qui décident d'options favorable aux
populations et à l'environnement
les innovations digital permettent à
monaco d'être également un laboratoire
environnementale l'application coach
carbone lancé par la principauté aide
les habitants à changer leurs
comportements pour réduire leur
empreinte carbone numérique permet
quelque part d'activer ces bonnes
volontés d'activer ces gestes
responsables d'activer cette vision pour
permettre de bien se comporter
depuis trois ans une autre application
permet à la principauté d'augmenter le
taux de recyclage du verre grâce à
l'application klink on peut remporter
des points en déposant ses bouteilles de
verre dans ces bornes
des points échangeables contre des bons
d'achat chez les commerçants locaux
le tri sélectif devient ludique et
l'impact sur l'environnement bien réel
notre application permet d'augmenter
d'environ 20%
le tri sélectif dont conscience mais à
l'échelle de par exemple 100 conteneurs
équipés pour le verre ça va représenter
pour la collectivité 300 tonnes de verre
supplémentaires qui vont être récoltées
et donc des économies de co2 qui vont
pouvoir être généré une solution où tout
le monde s'y retrouve
c'est un système gagnant gagnant à la
fois pour les citoyens pour les
commerçants mais aussi pour la
collectivité puisque les collectivités
vont pouvoir optimiser la gestion de
leurs déchets grâce à notre solution
puisqu'elles vont recevoir de la data en
temps réel que ce soit sur le niveau de
remplissage des conteneurs ou encore sur
la qualité du gisement qui est collecté
un dispositif qui a séduit la
principauté de nouvelles bornes vont
être prochainement équipés pour booster
le tri sélectif sur le territoire
monégasque l'économie dans nos régions
maintenant comme chaque semaine avec
vous michel picaud bonjour michel nous
partons cette semaine dans le nord à
lille plus précisément pour découvrir et
firent une start up qui s'est lancé dans
la vente immobilière est clair un
procédé très utilisée aux états unis et
qui se développe de plus en plus chez
nous depuis évidemment la pandémie sept
jours suffisent pour vendre son bien
l'esma michel bonjean sert il bonjour à
tous jamais autant de français des
citadins a notamment fait le choix de
quitter leur ville pour s'installer
ailleurs dans une ville moyenne ou
directement la campagne un phénomène qui
n'est pas près de s'arrêter vous diront
les professionnels de l'immobilier reste
une difficulté de taille vendre son bien
c'est ce qui a donné l'idée à
l'entreprise lilloise zéphyr de
développer la vente immobilière
instantanée déjà très utilisée aux états
unis vous voulez déménager et vendre au
plus vite votre maison votre appartement
zéphir propose donc de vous acheter au
prix du marché
votre bien immobilier en sept jours
seulement une fois le bien racheter
c'est assez fier de le revendre ensuite
depuis la création de cette start up
elle a acheté et revendu déjà 15 bien
les biens achetés par zéphyr ne dépasse
pas les 750 mille euros pour l'heure
mais la start-up voit grand une
et de fonds de 4 millions d'euros 30
embauches à l'automne prochain et une
offre couvrant l'ensemble du territoire
national aujourd'hui est fier c'est vit
uniquement sur l'île mais la start-up
entend bien révolutionner le marché de
l'immobilier rapidement merci michel
picon se retrouve dans une prochaine
édition de ce journal l'actualité des
territoires il en est également question
avec ces deux éditions spéciales sur les
villes de nantes et de montpellier de
l'hebdomadaire le point
le magazine s'intéresse notamment pour
l'édition danthez aux chantiers de
l'atlantique
parviendront-ils à prendre le virage
écologique c'est une question posée par
le journal l'écologie qui était
également un enjeu des élections
régionales dans les pays-de-la-loire
enfin vous découvrirez l'évolution
plutôt haut de gamme du vignoble nantais
dans l'édition montpelliéraine
l'hebdomadaire s'intéresse aux ambitions
économiques de la métropole après la
crise sanitaire
un entretien exclusif est aussi à lire
avec le maire socialiste le nouveau
maire de montpellier michaël delafosse
et puis tous les chiffres autour du boom
immobilier seront à découvrir enfin
d'édition de ce point spécial
montpellier restons en occitanie pour un
tout autre sujet près de perpignan le
parc éolien de rivesaltes
l'un des plus vieux de france va être
démantelée puis reconstruit ce chantier
est une première sur le plan national
les huit éoliennes vont être remplacés
par six nouvelles plus puissante mais
surtout plus respectueuse de
l'environnement
explications et détails d'alizée marty
pour vient occitanie sur place c'est à
rivesaltes dans les pyrénées orientales
que les premières éoliennes du
département ont été installés chili à
plus de 20 ans ce parc aujourd'hui
vieillissant va être démantelée puis
reconstruit ce chantier de reporting est
une première en france
avec les nouvelles éoliennes on va
pouvoir baisser les impacts paysagers
puisqu'on va seulement implanté six
éoliennes au lieu de huit
et pour autant va augmenter la
production de l'ordre de 50%
ça va permettre également avec les
nouvelles éoliennes de baisser
l'empreinte acoustique puisqu'il y aura
des innovations du biomimétisme
notamment on met des peigne acoustique
sur les pales d'éoliennes qui limite en
fait l'émission de décibels limiter
l'impact sur l'environnement c'est tout
l'enjeu de ces nouvelles éoliennes
elle devrait émettre 5 mille tonnes de
co2 en moins chaque année
alors que leur puissance va passer de 7
à 11 mégawatts aujourd'hui rivesaltes
est une ville qui est une ville positive
ne sommes plus de 9000 habitat et avec
cette nouvelle génération d'éoliennes
on aura une production pour à peu près
du gmail équivalents habitants dans du
simple au double le parc éolien
bénéficie des atouts naturels mais il
est aussi implanté à proximité de la
zone industrielle espace entreprises
méditerranée où plus de 300 emplois vont
être créés et de l'emploi bien entendu
pour le démontage et la valorisation des
pales d'éoliennes du travail et des
emplois pour le remontage et bien sûr
c'est une chaîne qui se fait avec deux
l'entretiennent de la valorisation de
l'énergie propre et moins cher et qui
diffuse et donc ça permet de continuer
le plan économique le nouveau parc
éolien de rivesaltes devrait voir le
jour en 2022
quant aux anciennes éoliennes elles
seront recyclées chez à 95%
c'est une conséquence négative est
désormais avéré déconfinement les
violences familiales ont augmenté depuis
plus d'un an en france pour y faire face
les collectivités multiplie les
initiatives dans les yvelines la ville
de ben a distribué cette semaine des
sacs à pain particuliers sont inscrits
dessus notamment les numéros d'urgence
en cas de violences un reportage dans
cette commune yvelinoise de mélanie
poquet pour tv 78 sur place
au premier coup d'oeil c'est sa cape
avons rien d'extraordinaire mais on y
trouve des numéros d'urgence et un
violent tôt m une initiative saluée
j'ai très bien de mettre des de diffuser
des messages qui sont importants pour
tout le monde vous faire prendre
conscience à tout le monde que c'est
important il faut les aider les femmes
qui sont violentes et je pense que c'est
bien de tirer l'attention de
des personnes sur ce qui se passe autour
de nous des sacs à pain pensé par la
mairie de vaines les deux boulangeries
de la commune ont été livrés ce mardi
1er juin
ma copine travaillant là dedans elle m'a
un peu sensibilisés à ça et ben moi j'ai
des gens que je connais qu'ils ont subis
et tout le monde perd quelqu'un qui
connaît qui ont acquis a subi sa est un
moment pour que ça s'arrête
un moyen d'entrer d'informer au sein
même des foyers pour la commune de 7500
habitants et milliers de sacs à pain que
nous avons fait imprimer vont permettre
de diffuser toutes ces informations
et on espère qu effectivement si dans
une famille on ne sait problème
intrafamiliaux qu'ils puissent prendre
appui sur ces sacs à pain pour se
libérer la parole dix mille sacs à pain
ont été remis ils viennent compléter les
actions d'associations et de gendarmerie
en 2019 près de 200 femmes hommes et
enfants sont morts de violences
intrafamiliales
chaque année près de 15 mille jeunes
intègrent le réseau associatif des
écoles de la deuxième chance une
opportunité pour ces jeunes souvent
désoeuvrés face aux études sans travail
et qui peuvent ainsi être formés et
accompagnés dans leur parcours en
martinique vous allez le voir plusieurs
d'entre eux ont découvert les métiers de
la mer
un secteur porteur où l'activité ne
manquent pas un reportage de tonnes
gagne ou pour vient à tv sur place
c'est parti pour la première activité de
la matinée la plongée et la découverte
des herbiers une demi-heure poupée du
monde au coeur de la biodiversité marine
de lille une véritable découverte pour
teddy ça m'a permis de découvrir qu'il y
a plusieurs types d herbe dans l'océan
surtout les herbiers et les différents
types d'espèces justement plusieurs
types de boissons
c'est plus de la découverte et
éventuellement orientation vers des
métiers qu'on ne connaît sa voie il
valait romeu durée car c'est aussi
l'objectif de cette journée
ces jeunes sont sortis du système
scolaire classique tous pris en charge
par l'école de la deuxième chance du sud
il découvre aujourd'hui les différents
métiers liés à la mer à la base c'est
pas ça mon métier professionnel au
projet professionnel mais ça m'a appris
autre chose atelier photo natation est
plongé encadrés par des professionnels
pour sortir de l'ornière autant plonger
dans le grand bleu c'est l'idée portée
par la structure pédagogique et un
constat des opportunités
professionnelles ne manquent pas sur le
littoral martinique
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir démocratiser
les métiers liés à la mer c'est à dire
de permettre aux jeunes de voir qu'il y
a la mère qui est un super potentiel qui
est mal exploité mal connus et qu'il ya
aussi des métiers qui sont en tension au
niveau de la mer à l'issue de cette
journée les stagiaires ont reçu
attestations et diplômes qualifiants une
première étape pour envisager d'autres
horizons d'une deuxième chance pour
l'océan mais aussi pour eux ils
débuteront le 23 juillet prochain les
jeux olympiques de tokyo ont dû être
repoussés bien sûr d'une année à cause
du coc vide
l'édition nippone n'en restera pas moins
marquée par la pandémie cet été et comme
tous les quatre ans les jeux
paralympiques se dérouleront aussi dans
la foulée du 24 août au 5 septembre
prochain à limoges la ville est devenue
depuis quelques semaines centre de
préparation officielle pour les équipes
de parra judo et de handi natation
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
de la rédaction locale c'est à limoges
les équipes de france peuvent profiter
d'infrastructures de haut standing et se
préparer ainsi à glaner j'espère
nombreuses médailles lors des
paralympiques de rio en 2016 la france
avait gagné 28 médailles dont 9 d'or se
plaçant ainsi 12e du classement
international
nous souhaitons évidemment bonne chance
à tous ces sportifs de haut niveau qui
représente fièrement notre pays lui ne
prépare pas les géo du japon mais ceux
de paris dans trois ans le danseur sékou
diagouraga s'est rendu dans une école du
mans pour faire découvrir sa discipline
le break dance
une discipline qui sera pour la première
fois au programme
et oui des jeux olympiques mais en 2024
une rencontre avec des écoliers donc
organisé dans le cadre d'un festival
margot bianco et milan loustallot de via
lmtv
non pas danser mais suivi cet atelier
hip hop
regardez entre deux répétitions pour
tenter de se qualifier aux jeux
olympiques 2000 24 dans la discipline
breakdance
le danseur sékou diagouraga du collectif
manceau legiteam obstruxion transmet
quelques mouvements de base aux élèves
c'est pas très courant mais je trouve ça
important parce que au-delà de juste de
l'aspect visuel
que les enfants aiment la danse
il ya aussi l'aspect culturel parce que
le hip hop c'est une très grande
histoire
c'est une belle histoire qui gère plus
de trente ans et qu'il jouera encore
très longtemps
réceptif les écoliers se plie à la
discipline avec brio à ya des moments
échanges joël nous et sont faciles et
puis cela dépenses et y met du sien
contre bas surtout les positions qu'il
faut vite changer de bras et il faut
être surtout sur ses appuis et après la
professeure en demande de ce projet est
fier du résultat sur sa classe je pense
que c'est un moyen vraiment démocratiser
la culture de se dire que ça n'est pas
réservé à une élite
c'est aussi tout à fait d'actualité
c'est vraiment très tendance le graphe
en ce moment les cultures urbaines ça
vraiment le vent en poupe après si je
peux donner un conseil à toutes les
écoles investissez ce monde là ça touche
à beaucoup d'enfants et beaucoup de
public
la suite du programme culturel pour ces
élèves c'est la visite de l'exposition
d'olga bartz à la mjc ronceray
partenaire du festival connexion de
super fort mal est dans moins d'un mois
c'est le tour de france qui débutera la
première étape partira de brest en
bretagne
de l'autre côté du pays dans les vosges
l'aventurier stéphane brogniart vient de
boucler lui son tour de france nommé
gallia 480 le vosgien a parcouru cinq
mille kilomètres en moins de 20 jours
un vrai tour de france sur lequel
revient à nicolas bré d'art de javols
sur place
le 3 mai dernier il s'élançait de paris
pour réaliser son tour de france à vélo
galy à 480 la gaule en moins de vingt
jours nouveau défi de l'ultra trailer
est désormais aventuriers vosgien
stéphane brogniart hauteur on le
rappelle de la traversée de l'océan
atlantique à la rame en solitaire l'an
passé au programme cette fois si près de
5000 km et 44 mille mètres de dénivelé
positif sur les routes et chemins de
l'hexagone encore il aura dû composer
avec une météo capricieuse vent pluie
grêle c'est le jeu mais a toujours pu
compter aussi sur le soutien de
nombreuses personnes sur son passage
grâce à un appel lancé sur les réseaux
sociaux pour les bergers faire un bout
de chemin avec lui ou simplement
l'encourager quelques ennuis mécaniques
forcément notamment ces derniers jours
sur les routes du nord
ici la trouée d'arenberg mythique
section pavés du paris roubaix
le gaillard n'a pas ménagé sa monture ni
son corps mais n'a pas connu de
blessures sinon l'usure physique et
psychologique
mais pas de quoi enrayer la bonne marche
de stéphane brogniart de retour dans les
vosges samedi matin ici du côté du col
de la schlucht bien accompagné sur les
dernières dizaines de kilomètres et
chaleureusement accueilli comme il se
doit chez lui à rochesson après avoir
rempli son défi en un peu moins de
quatre cent soixante dix neuf heures
déjà on est content d'arriver à ça fait
trois quatre jours que c'est dur dur dur
vraiment les les
les deux cent soixante dix de 160 à
assumer la au quotidien commencez à
devenir de plus en plus compliqué mois
on a cité aussi le but de l'opération
je peux dire vraiment c'est une vraie
réussite alors sportif pour moi mais
pour la limite ok mais après ce qui
était aussi le but de galien c'était
cette rencontre de la france à vélo de
la france qui qui va vers loki qui vit
ensemble et tout ça est vraiment une
belle réussite de l'exotisme il y en
aura en 2022 puisque stéphane brogniart
prévoit de traverser l'algérie acquis en
solitaire le long du méridien de
greenwich depuis la frontière avec le
mali jusqu'au or en 2000 km dont 1600 à
travers le sahara on termine cette
édition du grand jt des territoires à
marseille avec ses images de pleine
préparation fournis par nos partenaires
de la provence de l'exposition untitled
qui débutera dans une semaine au stade
vélodrome un lieu atypique il est vrai
mais qui retrace le parcours et la
réussite d'un groupe tout aussi atypique
les rolling stones ce 400 objets issus
de leurs collections seront donc à
découvrir sur près de 2000 m² untitled
débarque pour la première fois
france après avoir ébloui les fans du
monde entier
une exposition évidemment très attendue
à marseille écoutez à ce propos martin
d'agents lieu le directeur des grands
projets de l'olympique de marseille on a
toute l'histoire des rolling stones qui
a raconté à travers cette c'est très
sous espaces dans l'exposition avec des
murs d'imagés écrans
vous avez les costumes de scène nous
avait un studio d'enregistrement
reproduit en grandeur nature
vous avez les instruments originel du
groupe les guitares et batterie nous qui
avons été tous privés un peu de culture
pendant des mois c'est vraiment
l'occasion parce que c'est une occasion
unique sarr passera pas deux fois de
voir cette exposition extraordinaire qui
est qui est mondiale et qu'on a la
chance d'avoir à marseille cette année
voilà et puis précision les fans des
stones ont donc rendez vous à marseille
à partir du vendredi 10 juin
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi
sur tv5monde et sur vos chaînes locales
et régionales
on se retrouve pour une prochaine
édition très vite au revoir à tous et
bon courage
[Musique]